[موسيقى]
مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
الرياض نبداها بالعربي
خمسه
المركز الوطني لتنميه الحياه الفطريه يطلق
70 كائنا في المناطق البريه والمحميه
والمنتزهات
في الرابعه ايضا
العربيه تبدا سلسله التقارير من سلطنه
عمان وتتجول في سوق مطرح ابرزي معالم
العاصمه مسقط
[موسيقى]
ومنتخب التانجو بقياده ميسي يسعى للتحقيق
انجازي مارادونا امام نظيره الكرواتيه
كشفت مجله نيوز بيك الامريكيه عن تهريب
ايران شحنه من اليورانيوم المخصب الى
ميليشيا الحوتي في اليمن تسربت اجزاء منها
في ايدي عناصر تنظيم القاعده ولم ترد
المجله اي تفاصيل عن كيفيه وقوع اجزاء من
الشحنه بيد القاعده لكن هكذا الشحنه يمكن
استخدامها في صنع اسلحه نوويه
قالت ان ايران سلمت مؤخرا شحنه يورانيوم
للحوثيين تسرب جزء منها بيد تنظيم القاعده
[موسيقى]
الى الاحتجاجات في ايران وردود الفعل
الدوليه الغاضبه والمهدده باعدام الناشطين
حيث وصفت منظمه هيومن رايتس ووتش الدوليه
عمليات الاعدام التي نفذها نظام في ايران
بحق محتجين بالانتهاك الصارخي للعداله
والتصعيد الخطير للوطن وحضرت المنظمه في
تقرير لها من تفاصيل اعدام الشابين محسن
شكري ومجد رضا وعده اشخاص اخرين في خطر هم
الان وقالت الباحثه الايرانيه البارزه في
يوم رئيس سواتش تاره ان المتهمين يتعرضون
للتعذيب لاعتراف بتهم لم يرتكبوها ودخلتا
بانه وفقا للتقارير انه يتم الاحتياله على
الضمانات المنصوصه عليها في القانون
الجنائي وقانون الاجراءات الجنائيه
الايرانيه ووصفتها المنظمه الاحكام
الصادره عن القضاء كالافساده في الارض
والحراب بالاحكام الغامضه وشددت على ان
المحاكمه التي وصفتها بالمتعجله وال حرمت
المتهمين من الاتصال بمحامين من اختيارهم
هي بعيده كل البعد عن المعايير الدوليه
وقد اصدرت محاكم النظام الايراني ما لا
يقل عن احد عشر حكم بالاعدام على خلفيه
الاحتجاجات بحسب المنظمه التي توقعت ايضا
ادانه العشرات بينهم اطفال بتهمم قد تؤدي
الى عقوبه الاعدام
الايرانيه الدكتور حسن هاشميان
دكتور حسن مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه
ولنا امام حنا حمله يعني الغضب والضغوط
الدوليه للنظام الايراني الى اي مدى يمكن
ان يسير هذا النظام في احكام الاعدام
للمحتاجين
العربيه طبعا النظام الايراني حاول من
خلال هذه الاجراءات بنات جدار الخوف من
جديد الذي تحطم اثناء المظاهرات
والاحتجاجات وايضا هناك يحاول الضغط
الى اعترافه انهم لم يقبلوا الروايه
الايرانيه
الضغوطات ولذلك اتخذ هذه الاجراءات ولكن
الحركه التي جاءت في العالم وخاصه من
الاتحاد الاوروبي حركه كانت جدا متطوره
تضرب على قات هذا النظام الذي محتاجها
تماما مع الاتحاد الاوروبي تضرب هذه
العلاقات وتضغط على النظام الايراني
الاتحاد الاوروبي 27 دوله
على هذا النظام وايضا همم يتوجه الى همم
تخصيذ جديده
بصلاحيه قانونيه لاحتغال كل متورط بموضوع
الاعدامات وموضوع الاعتقالات
والمسيره التي الان موجوده في داخل ايران
هل نقطه الاخرى ان النظام الايراني حاول
من خلال هذه الاجراءات يشد حبل هؤلاء
الموالين حول
ويستغوي بهم النتائج جاءت عكسيه لان هناك
كانت
موجه من داخل النظام الى علي خامني بهذه
الاجراءات ايضا حتى راينا صحيفه جمهوريه
اسلاميه وهي صحيفه متشدده توجه الانتدابات
انهم يعملوا بلاغ قانونيه بهذه الطريقه
هذه الاجراءات ولذلك في هذه همم الاجراءات
النظام الايراني لم يصل الى اهدافه لكن
المحتاجين والمتظاهرين هل
يعني ارهبهم او ارهابتهم هذه الاحكام
وسياسه الاعدام على الرافعه التي شاهدناها
يعني في في حق المحتل الشكري
نحن الان
في كردستان في مدينه
في شمال ايران في مركز ايران ولذلك هذا
كلها تدل على ان النظام الايراني لا
يستطيع بناء جدار الخوف من جديد وانما
هناك ياتي بموج جديد من الغضب الجماهيري
تجاري يعني هذه الاجراءات همم
نشرت غضب جماهير ضد النظام الايراني
في الايام القادمه من خلال همم التضارات
الجديده والاحتجاجات الجديده ضد هذا
النظام كيف تصف انت الموقف الدولي الان
امام حمله القمه استخدام احكام الاعدام من
قبل النظام الايراني بحق المحتاجين والى
اي مدى يمكن ان يصل برايه
انا اعتقد الموقف الاوروبي كان موقف متطور
وموقف متقدم بالنسبه للاجراءات السابقه
اولا فيما يتعلق بحقوق الانسان في ايران
فيما يتعلق في موضوع الملف النووي
والمفاوضات النوويه ولكن هناك ينقصه بعض
الاشياء مثلا التحرك على
المؤسسات الدوليه يجب ان نشهد هناك تحرك
اولا من مجلس حقوق الانسان الى مجلس همم
الامن في الامم المتحده ايضا يجب نشهد ان
هناك تحركات في الجمعيه العامه تجاه
النظام الايراني ويجب
طرح موضوع عن الاب فرق بين النظام
الايراني وداعش ويجب ان يتعامل العالم مع
النظام الايراني مثل ما كان يتعامل مع
داعش لان كل المؤشرات تقول بان نظام
الوليه الفريق في ايران في هذه الاجراءات
في مواجهه الشعب وقتل المواطنين لا فرق
بينه ولا وموضوع داعش شكرا جزيلا لكم من
واشنطن الباحث في شان الايراني دكتور حسن
هاشميا
رابع بعد قليل في حركه لافته 25 مشروعا
لتطوير الاسكان في مدينه جده
اهلا بكم من جديد في السعوديه اصدرت وزاره
الحج والعمره اربعه ملايين تاشيره عمره
لجميع المعتمرين القادمين من الخارج خلال
خمسه اشهر منذ بدا موسم العمره العام
الجاري التي توافق الاف المعتمرين من
الخارج وسط مجموعه من الخدمات والتسهيلات
من بينها استثناء معتمري عدد من الدول من
شرط العمره والغاء الاجراءات الصحيه
الخاصه بفيروس
[موسيقى]
من مكه المكرمه ينضم الينا وكيل وزاره
الحج والعمره للشؤون العمره عبد الرحمن بن
فهد شمس سيد عبد الرحمن اهلا وسهلا بك معي
في نشره الرابعه اولا في وزاره الحج يعني
ما هي قراءتكم لهذا العدد وصول العدد عدد
تاشيرات العمره الى 4 ملايين يعني اربعه
ملايين تاشيره في خمسه اشهر رقم كبيره
الجميعات العامله في منظومه الحج والعمره
كلنا نسعى لتحقيق رؤيه المملكه
والرحمن همم يعني هذه الاعداد
جاءت بعد عده مبادرات
واجراءات عملنا على تيسيرها مع الجهات
المهنيه معنا
بحمد الله يعني همم اسفلت للوصول لهذا
العدد الكبير ولازمنا نتوقع بمشيئه الله
خلال همم يعني هذا الموسم المزيد من هذا
الاعداء وما هي اهم هذه الخدمات
والتسهيلات التي قدمت يعني خلال الفتره
السابقه مقارنه همم يعني همم الفترات
الاخرى همم ايضا قبل ذلك
نعم اليوم اصبح بمقدور من يرغب في اداء
العمره من خارج المملكه من خلال منصه
النسك
التعرف على كل القنوات المتاحه له
والاجراءات المطلوبه منه للقدوم الى
المملكه العربيه السعوديه وهذا يعني ييسر
على المعتمرين همم الكثير من الجهود التي
كانت السابق يحتاج ان هو يبذلها للوصول
الى معلومات معينه او الاجراءات المطلوبه
منه باختلاف الحالات وباختلاف يعني طبيعه
المعتمرين وتاشيراتهم من خلال هذه المنصه
يعني اصبح يعني يوضح للمعتمر انه يستطيع
همم اداء العمره او الصلاه في الروضه
الشريفه بمجرد قدومه للمملكه في اي نوع من
انواع التاشيرات فكانت هذه اول خطوه انه
اداء العمره اليوم ما اصبح مرتبط بنوع
تاشيره محدد كل من يقدم الى المملكه باي
نوع من انواع التاشيرات فهو قادر على اداء
العمره وبالتالي مزرعه السياحه والقادمي
للسياحه او القادمين بغرض الزياره الشخصيه
او حتى القادمين باغراض اخرى مختلفه كلهم
اصبحوا قادرين على همم اداء العمره وهذا
اسهل بشكل كبير في زياده الاعداد ايضا على
مستوى الاجراءات ال- ال- المطلوبه لاصدار
هذه التاشيرات صار هناك يعني كثير من
اعاده هندسه هذه الاجراءات
التقليص المده الزمنيه التي كانت تستغرق
السابق همم في اصدار التاشيراتي اصبحت
الان في دقائق معدوده وبتاشيره الكترونيه
ليس هناك اي متطلبات يعني همم يعني تؤدي
الى تاخر في في انجاز هذه الاجراءات هذا
ايضا اسهم بشكل واضح وهو من الامور يعني
ايضا المهمه اللي ساعدت همم الزوار
المعتمرين خارج المملكه انهم يخططوا مسبقا
لرحلتهم الان بامكانه من خلال تطبيق وهو
موجود في همم في دولته يستطيع التعرف على
همم الاوقات متاحه لاداء العمره والاوقات
الاقل ازدحاما وبالتالي يختار الوقت
المناسب له ويبني تخطيط رحلته بناء على
معلومه واضحه
ويصدر بموجبها التصريح لاداء العمره في
الروضه بالاضافه الى التطبيقات مثل
التطبيق النسك هل هناك عوامل اخرى اسهمت
في زياده هذا العدد بنسبه الاقبال على
التاشيرات العمره من ناحيه مزودين خدمات
مثلا بالقطاع الخاص
همم اليوم نحن بنعمل على تطوير التجربه
وتحسين التجربه للمعتبر على مدار الرحله
اليوم بفضل الله مملكتنا الحبيبه تنسخر
بالعديد من يعني المعالي والمعاليات وهمم
الامور التي بالامكان ان تسري برنامج
المعتم من خلال فتوقعوه هذا المحفز يعني
همم جذب الكثير من
المعتمرين او الزوار للمملكه بحيث انه هو
بعد فراغ من اداء الدسوق يستطيع من خلال
تواجه المملكه خاصه مع تمديد فتره مده
تاشيره الى ثلاثه اشهر هذا اعطى مساحه
اكبر انه هو يستفيد من هذه الفتره في
التحرك في مدن المملكه مختلفه اضافه
للعمال شكرا جزيلا لك من مكه المكرمه وكيل
وزاره الحج والعمره لشؤون العمره عبد
الرحمن بن فهد شمس
شكرا لك
اشهد مدينه جده غرب السعوديه حراك كبير في
مشاريع الاسكان خلال الفتره الماضيه وذلك
ضمن الخطط التي وضعت لتطوير المشاريع
السكنيه بلغ عدد المشاريع الاسكانيه في
مدينه جده 25 مشروعا يجري العمل على البعض
منها في حين تم الانتهاء من بعض المشاريع
تتضمن عددا من الضواحي السكنيه التي توفر
اسلوب حياه عصريه متكامل وتضم عددا من
المرافق التعليميه والصحيه والامنيه
والترفيهيه
من جده ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه سعود
الخلف سعود مرحبا بك ما هي اهم هذه
المشاريع الان التي تحظى بها مشاريع
السكنيه التي تحتوي بها مدينه جده
تشهد تزايد خلال هذا العام في عدد
المشاريع تصل الى اكثر من 20 مشروع وراح
توفر اكثر من 57000 وحده سكنيه احنا الان
في مشروع ضاحيه ضاحيه الجوهره وفي ايضا
مشاريع ضاحيه خياله وضاحيه الميار وهي
تقريبا الابرز لوزاره الاسكان في تفاصيل
كثيره عن هذه المشاريع عن اسعارها عن
مساحاتها وتفاصيل ايضا بناءها ولكن اسمح
لي خالد ان يكون معي ال- الاستاذ سليمان
شيري هو من احد همم 11 شركات المطوره
لمشاريع همم وزاره الاسكان وتحديدا في
ضاحيه الجوهره لياخذ منها المعلومات
التفصليه يعطيك العافيه استاذ سليمان احنا
موجودين الان في مشروع ضاحيه الجوهره
ويتبادل عندما نستمع الى كلمه ضاحيه بانه
هذا المكان وبعيد عن المدينه وبعيد عن
الخدمات هل هذا المفهوم ينطبق على هذا
المشروع ام انه يختلف تماما اول شيء حياكم
الله تشرفنا فيكم همم بالنسبه لمعنى او
مسمى ضاحيه في مشاريع وزاره الاسكان اطلق
هذا المسمى همم الضاحيه على المجمعات
السكنيه التي تتوفر فيها جميع الخدمات
اللي يتلبي احتياجات الساكن همم اختلف
المعنى للمسمى الضاحيه فاليوم انت لما
تشوف الضواحي سكنيه لوزاره الاسكان
بتتفاجا انه المشاريع هذه متكامله احتياجك
بيكون داخل الضاحيه هذه ما تحتاج في
احتياجاتك الاساسيه اليوميه انك تخرج خارج
الضاحيه عشان تقضيها وتشتريها يعني سكان
الضاحيه لن يكونوا الا من شريحه معينه وهم
المدعومين من وزاره الاسكان صحيح وزاره
الاسكان خاصه الضواحي السكنيه
فقط مستحقي الدعم السكني من وزاره الاسكان
لو بنتكلم عن المساحات وعن الاسعار في هذه
المشاريع فينا بالنسبه للمساحات الاسعار
المساحات والاسعار طبعا همم انت تتكلم عن
مشاريع مختلفه نماذج وتفاصيل مختلفه
فضروري انه يكون فيه اسعار مختلفه وتصاميم
مختلفه يعني تبدا نتكلم اذا تكلمنا في
السعر نتكلم تقريبا من 300,000 ريال تبدا
توصل الى مليون و200 طبعا في بعض المشاريع
حسب كل مشروع وخصوصيته همم المساحات تبدا
من 130 متر طبعا للمساحات الصغيره توصل
الى 400 متر حسب رغبه العميل وقدره
الماليه الشرائيه طيب جميل في بعض الوحدات
السكنيه تكون متساويه في المساحه ولكن
تكون مختلفه بشكل كبير في الاسعار
طبعا اولا كل مشروع له خصوصيته فبعض
المشاريع السكنيه بتستخدم تقنيات بين تكون
تكلفتها عاليه اضافتنا الى انه مواد
التشطيب الداخليه في المباني تختلف من
مشروع الى مشروع
هذا ممكن انه يسبب نوع من التنافس في من
ناحيه الاسعار همم مهم او تحرس الديار انه
يكون مشاريعها ذا جوده عاليه فممكن انه
يكون في اختلاف في بعض الاسعار في بعض
المشاريع لكن بشكل عام الاسعار متقاربه
بشكل كبير جدا ذكرت لانه في اختلاف في
طريقه البناء يعني في شيء بالبلوكه وفي
شيء بالخرسانه لو تشرح لنا اياه صحيح طبعا
في تقنيات اليوم تقنيات البنات اختلفت
بشكل كبير في عندك البريكاس زي المستخدم
هنا في المشروع بوفيه في عندك ثري دي
برنتر هذه طابعات تطبع الخرسانه بشكل حسب
التصميم المقترح في البناء التقليدي اللي
متعارف عليه وهو البلوك طبعا كل ما اختلف
التقنيه البينه كل ما زادت الاسعار
والتكلفه فكل مشروع له خصوصيته ويتحدد
الاسعار بناء على المواد المستخدمه او
طريقه البناء شكرا جزيلا العفو تشرفنا
حياك الله اهلا وسهلا يعني خالد نبذه
سريعه عن المشاريع في همم الضواحي الثلاثه
الجوهره وخياله الميار شكرا لك يعطيك
العافيه من جده مراسل العربيه سعود الخلف
في السعوديه اطلق المركز الوطني لتنميه
الحياه الفطريه السبعين كائنا في عدد من
المناطق البريه والمحميه والمنتزهات
الوطنيه وذلك منذ منذ بدء موسم الاطلقات
اعشار الماضي ضمن خطط اطلاق مئات الكائنات
في مختلف المناطق على مدى خمسه اشهر كان
المركز نجح في اطلاق 1100 كائن خلال
الموسم الماضي بزياده 66% عن عدد الكائنات
المطلقه في موسم عام 2020 ضمن برنامج
الاكثار الذي يستهدف عده كائنات حيه
الرياض العربيه نواف عزيز نواف حياك الله
معي ايضا في نشره الرابعه الان ما المختلف
في برنامج الاكثار هذا العام مقارنه
بالعوامل الماضيه
نعم خالد اهلا بك حوالي 2000 كائن فطري
يتواجد هنا في احدى حظائر الاكثار التابعه
للمركز الوطني لتنميه الحياه الفطريه جهود
متغيره عاما بعد عام ولاحظ في هذا العام
ان المركز يبدو انه سيطلق اعداد اكبر من
الكائنات الفطريه في المنتزهات وايضا في
المحميات وفي المناطق البريه بمختلف مناطق
المملكه ربما يكون هناك اعداد اكبر عن
الاعداد الماضيه التي اطلقت خلال الموسم
الماضي 2021 2020 وهي 1,200 كائن هنا
يتبين كيف تتم عمليه همم احتضان الكائنات
الفطريه النادره من خلال 200 حظيره تحت ظل
هذه الكائنات وسنكون الان من احدى همم
الحظائر التي تحتوي على الكائنات الفطريه
النادره ومعي الان الدكتور محمد الدغيم
المسؤول عن هذه الحظائر اهلا وسهلا دكتور
في البدايه كيف تعملون على اكثار الكائنات
الفطريه النادره من هذا المكان حياك الله
اخوي نواف همم مركز الملك خالد لابحاث
الحياه الفطريه هو احد المراكز التابعه
للمركز الوطني لتنميه الحياه الفطريه
ويهدف المركز الى اعاده كثار الحيوانات
المهدده المنقرضه همم الحيوانات المهدده
بالانقراض
واعاده كثثارها واطلاقها في المحميات
الملكيه والمحميات التابعه للمركز الوطني
لتنميه الحياه الفطريه والمنتزهات الوطنيه
ودور المركز والحفاظ على صحه الحيوان اولا
وتحصينه ضد الامراض الموجوده في المملكه
في في بخصوصا الامراض لو حسن انا مرض همم
يتم تشريح الحيوانات واخذ عينات للمختبر
لاجراء الدراسات لمعرفه ايش الاسباب
الامراض الموجوده نعم دكتور الان
الحيوانات او الكائنات الفطريه النادره
الموجوده هنا ايش انواعها وابرز الكائنات
اللي تركزون عليها في هنا في الحضاره يعني
همم اهم همم الحيوانات الموجوده اللي هي
الظلفيات همم عندنا اربع برامج كثار همم
البرنامج الاول هو اللي هو اكثر همم الريم
والربي همم الادمي وعندنا برنامج اكسسوار
المها العربي والوعل النوبي
الثانويه
الانتاج الريم ابو ظبي الريم موسمي يختلف
عن باقي البرامج الثانيه
الثانوي من شهر من من من من شهر الخريب من
الموسم الخريب الى الموسم الربيع ينتج فيه
الغزال الادمي والريم
توام في السنه مره واحده البرامج الثانيه
سنويه همم لا يوجد لها موسم اكثار همم
محدد طول السنه تنتج نعم دكتور الان همم
عمليه الحفاظ على صحه الكائنات الفطريه
النادره هنا الروتين اليومي لكم همم طبي
يعني او البيطري نعم هو الروتين المتابعه
يوميا للوضع الصحي العام
للمركز همم متابعه التغذيه ونوعيه التغذيه
ومتابعه الحالات الفرديه همم
همم كسور بسيطه
وتعشر في الولاده فيحتاج تدخل طب الطبيب
البيطري يعمل العمليات او للتجبير او
العلاج المناسب مع وجود تطعيمات سنويه
تطعم قدام امراض همم
موسميه في تحصل في المملكه
نعم دكتور يعني مثل ما نشوف الان ال- همم
الكائنات اللي هنا اللي هي ظبي همم الريم
نعم غير معتاده ممكن على همم الغرباء يعني
كيف ممكن يفسر يعني هذه الحاله يعني في
المركز نحاول نوفر همم بيئتها الطبيعيه
بقدر المستطاع وعدم تدخل همم
الشغالين هنا موظفين او العماله تدخل مع
الحيوانات بحيث لما ترجع يتلاقى في
المحميه تكون همم
ما هي مستانسه زي على تكون على طبيعتها
تنطلق في البراري يعني والمحميات
نعم كل الشكر لك الدكتور محمد اذا خالد
يعني كمان وشاهد العديد من الحظائر هنا
والجهود يعني ربما هذا المركز او هذه
الحظائر قديمه ولكن خلال السنوات القليله
الماضيه يزدادت بشكل كبير جدا وهناك
العديد من الخطط لاطلاق المزيد من البرامج
مثل
الخطط لاحتضان الفهود وايضا فصائل اخرى من
القطط النادره الجهود مستمره وربما يكون
هذا هذا المركز او هذه الحظائر الواحده من
احدى الحضائر المتواجده او التابعه للمركز
الوطني لتنميه الغطاء شكرا
او عفوا الغطاء
ههه طيب
خرجت اكاديميه الطويقت تابعه للاتحاد
السعودي للامن السيبراني 20 طالبا وطالبه
اكملوا معسكر تويك وعلي بابا للحوسبه
السحابيه وحصلوا على شهادات احترافيه
وافاد الرئيس التنفيذي الاكاديمي عبد
العزيز الحمادي من هذه الدفعه هي الاولى
من المعسكرات التي تقام بالشراكه بين
اكاديميه الطويق والشركه السعوديه للحوسبه
السحابيه مضيفا بان الاكاديميه ستعاملوا
على تخريج المزيد من الدفاعات
اعلانات وزاره العدل السعوديه عن انطلاق
خدمه التوثيق الوصيه الالكترونيه عبر منصه
[__] وبينت الوزاره ان الخدمه متاح
للمستفيدين عبر بوابه ناجز بخطوات ميسره
متاحه بان الخدمه الجديده تختصر وقت
المستفيدين
وتغنيهم عن زيارتك كتابه العدل
رابع ايضا مستمره في ابها بعد قليل
وزاره الثقافه تحتفي بالعرض السعوديه كاحد
عناصر التراث الثقافي السعودي
تقرير الامريكيه يكشف عن شحنه يورانيوم
ايرانيه هربت الى الحوثيين ووقع جزء منها
4 ملايين تاشيره عمره خلال خمسه اشهر
المركز الوطني لتنميه الحياه الفطريه يطرق
70 كائنا في المناطق البريه والمحميات
والمنتزهات
العربيه تبدا سلسله التقارير من سلطنه
عمان وتتجول في سوق مطرح ابرز معالم
العاصمه مسقط
[موسيقى]
ومنتخبات ميسي يسعى لتحقيق انجاز مارادونا
امام نظيره الكروتي ونجمه المخضرم مدرج
اهلا بكم يستمر معرض العرضه السعوديه الذي
اطلقته وزاره الثقافه في ساحه الصفات في
الرياض باستقبال الزوار هذا المعرض واحتفت
من خلاله الوزاره بواحد من عناصر التراث
الثقافي والسعودي وابرزت قيمته الثقافيه
ومدى ارتباطه بالهويه الوطنيه غاد الفهد
يستمر معرض العرضه السعوديه الذي اطلقته
وزاره الثقافه في ساحه الصفات في الرياض
باستقبال الزوار هذا المعرض احتفت من
خلاله الوزاره بواحد من عناصر التراث
الثقافي السعودي
وابرزت قيمته الثقافيه وما ترتيباته
بالهويه الوطنيه
وهل العوده على ما قال ايه وعنا والله سوى
صغار يعني ونكمل من سيره اجدادنا وباتنا
من قبلنا يعني هو شعور جميل بصراحه وانا
عشان منوه وانا صغير بالعرض يعني شاتي
مجروعه يعني
وطرق النجديه الى جانب تاديه العرض
السعوديه كما يتضمن المعرض جناح العرضه
عالميا الذي يجمع صورا متنوعه لعدد
الرؤساء دول العالم والدبلوماسيين
الباريين لحظه اداءهم للعرض اثناء زيارتهم
للمملكه
العربيه السعوديه وهي العرضه الذي تتمثل
فيها نوعيه الشجاعه والنخوه
همم الرجوله ومدلولها الجميل الذي يدل على
الفزعه
واللحميه هذا يعني شيء نعتز فيه جميعا
يعني تعتز فيه المملكه العربيه السعوديه
سواء شمالها شرقها 4 جيوبها وهذا شيء جميل
جدا يعني وهي العرض هي السعوديه تتمارس في
جميع انحاء المملكه العربيه السعوديه
العامه
السعوديه الى التعريف بها بوصفها فنان
سعوديا اصيلا وتصحيح المفاهيم المرتبطه
بها اضافه للاحتفاء بها باعتبارها تراثا
ثقافيا عالميا غير مادي مسجلا لدى
اليونسكو منذ عام 2015 غدا الفهد العربيه
الرياض
هنا ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن
سلمان العائله المغربيه الملك محمد السادس
خلال اتصال هاتفي بل انجاز التاريخي
للمنتخب المغربي في بطوله كاس العالم في
قطر مؤكدا انما تحقق يعد انجازا رياضيا
عربيا اسعد الجميع واعرب عن تمنياته
بالتوفيق للمنتخب المغربي
الاسواق الشعبيه هي رئه المدن ونبضها
الحقيقي لذلك يعتبر سوق مطرح تاريخي في
العاصمه العمانيه مسقط من ابرز معالمها
الحيويه ازقه العتيقه لا تخلو من الزوار
والسياح على مدار العام لجانب حرس الكثير
من تجار السوق العمانيين على التوريد
تجارتهم ومهنهم لابناءهم حفاظا على تقاليد
السوق وتاريخه الطويل عبد الرحمن العصيمي
زار هذا السوق
وانطلاقه سلسله التقاريره من عمان
[موسيقى]
هنا سوق مطرح اكثر المواقع حيويه في
العاصمه العمانيه مسقط الذي يعود تاريخه
لاكثر من 200 عام
[موسيقى]
هذا السوق شاهد حي على الاسواق الكلاسيكيه
في المنطقه حيث تتمثل بين اسقته ومحاله
الصور الاجتماعيه والمعالم العمرانيه
للسلطنه
[موسيقى]
بضائع متنوعه هنا في سوق مطرح التاريخي
باسعار مناسبه للغايه كما نشاهد هذا الشال
من القماش الكشميري الفاخر قيمته تقريبا
عشره ريالات عماني اين يقارب 30 دولار
امريكي ايضا هناك بضائع اخرى متنوعه كما
نشاهد الهدايا التذكاريه التحف الالعاب
بالاضافه الى العطورات
واللبان العماني
[موسيقى]
جمال محمد علي يعمل في سوق مطرح منذ سنوات
ورث هذه التجاره من والده ويامل ان يستمر
ابنائه من بعده في هذا السوق حفاظا على
موروث العائله التجاريه
لما يطلعون من المدارس يكون ايام الاجازات
الجمعه
غرس الحب على
الاعمال المحلات التجاريه على الاسواق
التقليديه
[موسيقى]
سوق مطرح يقع في الجهه المقابله لميناء
السلطان قابوس الذي لطالما كان وجهه
الرئيسيه للقوافل التجاريه والبضائع
القادمه من الشرق والغرب ليكتسب من هذه
الادوار اسم مطرح بمعنى المكان الذي تطرح
فيه البضائع للزوار والمتفوقين
عبد الرحمن العصيمي من العاصمه العمانيه
مسقط العربيه
[موسيقى]
في مثل هذا اليوم قبل 66 عاما استمر الطول
الامطار على بعض المناطق في السعوديه لمده
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
سنه وبالتحديد في 13 ديسمبر عام
1956 11 جمادى الاولى عام
1376 هطلت امطار غزيره على نجم الرياض
سدير الوشم الغاط المجمعه الزلفي
الارطاويه وعمو منطقه القصيم واستمر هطول
الامطار لمده 58 يوما دون انقطاع وتركز
هطولها على بريده والزلفي فتهدم 3000 منزل
ببريده واسماؤها سنتردام وغارقه المنازل
التي في المنخفضات بالسلفي واسماؤها سنتر
غرقا وجرى لا مره وبنفس اللحظه اكبر اوديه
ثلج وادي الرموه وادي حنيفه كلن حزين وقام
يصفق بيمناه من الكدر ما احد درى بس سريره
اللي غرق واللي ظهر يجري رداء واصبح يشوف
القش كله
مثيره
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
والحوادث الكونيه قد تفرض نفسها على
التاريخ فتسمى السنه باسمها سنه الجوع
1910 الموافق
1328 سنه هجري
1939,358 سنه الظلمه اللي كسوف الشمس
1952,371 هجري تذكرت ليله والسنين
الخواليه وايام لا نخشى على اللهو ناهيه
وقد يجمع الله الشتيتين بعد ما يظنني كل
الظن الا
تلاقيه
[موسيقى]
تقرير الامريكيه يكشف عن شحنه يورانيوم
المركز الوطني لتنميه الحياه الفطريه يطلق
70 كائنا في المناطق البريه والمحميات
والمنتزهات
العربيه تبدا سلسله التقارير من سلطنه
عمان وتتجول في سوق مطرح ابرز معالم
العاصمه العمانيه
[موسيقى]